ukrainian refugees being welcomed at
this shelter in tijuana
olga arrived just this morning after
traveling more than 9 000 kilometers
with her cat snips she's now being
looked after by ukrainian american
volunteers who have assigned her a
number the number represents a spot in
line to plead her case for refugee
status to u.s authorities she tells us
the whole experience feels surreal
you feel happiness and then you have
another wave of emotions like you're sad
you're reading all the time in you so
it's
it's totally different reality right now
and it's
hard
to to get to the point when you feel
that
happiness as you used to
feel before so
it will take a while of course
many here have been traveling for weeks
they arrive tired hungry and confused
most don't speak spanish or english and
are relying entirely on help from
volunteers
first of all they all nervous because
lots of of them they've never been in in
in mexico they know that tijuana is
dangerous place
so when they come into in the airport
they a little bit nervous thing we're
trying to keep calm them and tell them
relax
we will we will help you how we can we
will help you
there are also dozens of families here
with young children
they spend much of their time listening
carefully in case their numbers are
called though many seem eager to cross
the border into the united states
others tell us what they want is to go
home
i'm feel
very tired of course
i hope that soon i will come to ukraine
i'm not going to stay in usa for long
i hope that in summer i can
come back to my country to my family to
my mother my brothers and all that left
here
more than
000 ukrainians have arrived in tijuana
since the start of the war in february
since mexico has not imposed any
restrictions on ukrainian travelers more
are arriving every day
conditions may seem crowded at this
refugee camp in the city of tijuana
right on the border with the united
states but new arrivals have actually
declined in recent days local
authorities however tell us that the
population here is likely to grow
significantly in the coming weeks
u.s border officials are processing
about 50 ukrainian refugees every hour
while ukrainians arriving in tijuana
only stay at the shelter for a few days
new arrivals are quick to take the place
of those who leave
though there's concern the sports
complex being used to house refugees
could soon overflow
state officials say a second shelter
could quickly be made available if
needed
manuel rapalo al jazeera tijuana mexico